Do you carry around
one phone for work
and another phone
for personal use?
Do you wish you
could just carry one?
The desire to have one device
for both work and personal use
is a common one, but often
due to very valid reasons
like security, it isn't
possible for many people.
With Android for
Work, IT Management
can set up your personal
device for secure use at work
while you maintain
control of your device
and your personal information.
I'm Gene Trinks, and I'm going
to run through our solution
for using Android devices
for both work and play.
Android has evolved to add
secure management of data
and apps that can be
consistently applied
across devices, be it the
traditional premium devices
used today in many companies,
or the lower cost, high volume
devices used by over a billion
people around the world,
or the many single use corporate
or kiosk type applications.
All of these variations
can be work enabled,
and best of all they remain
easy to use by the end user.
Introduced in early
2015, Android for Work
brings the best
features of Android
to the enterprise, including
our focus on Android innovation,
our great device ecosystem,
app development, and device
management capabilities.
Android for Work comprises
features in two areas,
enhancements to the
Android device experience,
and new tools for our partners
to add value in the enterprise.
Devices get enhancements to
Android and Lollipop and newer
to support work profiles, an app
that allows for the same user
experience on older devices,
Google Play for work
for securely distributing
apps, and built-in productivity
tools to make sure everyone has
a consistent user experience
no matter what
device they choose.
For our partners,
the main features
are new interfaces for
enterprise mobility management
partners to control
and administer
every aspect of this enterprise
experience, new interfaces
for app developers that allow
EMM partners to remotely
configure enterprise
apps for end users,
and of course Android remains an
open platform where our device
partners can continue
to innovate and add
additional features.
Let's dig a little
deeper into what's
new in Android for Work devices.
As we mentioned earlier,
Android for Work and Lollipop,
which is Android 5.0,
introduces the concept
of work profiles, the ability
to securely separate work
data from personal data, and
allow the enterprise to control
only the work profile.
This allows you to still
maintain your privacy
on the device that you bring
into work, known as BYOD.
Built right into Android,
this data separation
is achieved through a
combination of full device
encryption, coupled
with multi-user support.
Picture a work user
and a personal user
running simultaneously
on one device.
In addition to separating
data on the device,
it also allows IT
admins to control which
apps can communicate
with each other,
and allows for the optional
obfuscation of notifications,
to protect company data
when your device is locked
and you receive a new
work email, for example.
For the end user, the
experience is seamless.
Work apps live
alongside personal apps
and are denoted by the Android
for Work briefcase badge.
And our EMM partners
have integrated
all these capabilities
into the mobile device
management consoles that your
IT department is using today.
For devices that are not running
Android version 5.0 or newer,
and some Lollipop devices
that don't support profiles,
we've provided the
Android for Work app.
It offers backwards
compatibility going back
to Android version 4.0,
Ice Cream Sandwich.
This app can be downloaded
from the Play Store,
and uses container technology
to provide a very similar user
experience as those
newer devices.
Things like badged work
apps, separation of data,
restriction of intents, which
is data sharing across apps,
and it allows management
through that same console
that your IT department
is already using.
One of the most important
features of Android for Work
is its use of
Google Play for work
as the method for distributing
and managing applications
for the work profile.
Enterprises can choose
any app, free or paid,
from the Google Play
Store and whitelist it
for optional installation
into the work profile.
They can also silently push
apps into the work profile.
Bulk purchasing is now
supported for paid apps,
and custom apps can
also be deployed
utilizing a private
channel on Google
Play for restricted
access to only users
in your organization.
The Android for Work app
supports a more limited set
of apps from the
Google Play Store,
but the experience is the same,
whitelisting apps and deploying
them via Google Play.
It's important to note
that only apps that
have been approved ahead of
time and whitelisted by IT
can be installed into
the work profile,
and they must come from
the Google Play Store,
so there's no risk of
any unapproved apps.
And again, all of
this is controlled
by your EMM via policy
through the management tools
that you use today.
All of this control applies
to the work profile,
or the Android for Work app.
If it's a BYOD device,
the user can still
use their own apps
on the personal side,
and the data never
gets combined.
And if it's a BYOD
device, the company
can't wipe your personal data.
To make the user
experience consistent
across all different devices
on different OS versions
from different manufacturers,
Android for Work
provides a full suite of
optional productivity tools.
There's a PIM suite, email,
contacts, calendar, tasks,
that supports Exchange and
Lotus Notes via Activesync,
with Advanced
Enterprise features
like S/MIME encrypted email,
and free/busy look up.
Doc sheets and slides are
provided for the editing
of email attachments.
These work in office
compatibility mode
and provide the ability to edit
and save and attach to emails.
There's a PDF viewer, and Chrome
is provided as the browser.
Google Apps users would use
Gmail instead of the PIM suite,
but they also get access to the
additional online collaborative
features of doc
sheets and slides.
All of these apps
can be configured
remotely by the enterprise
to reduce complexity
for the end user.
For example, pre-populating
server settings, or proxies,
or bookmarks in
Chrome, et cetera.
In fact, any ISV can make use of
these new remote configuration
capabilities to make their
apps easier to deploy
in the enterprise too.
We've talked a bit about some
of the new features in Android
for Work and the
end user experience,
but it's critical to note that
there's a lot more going on
behind the scenes, and we
rely on our partner ecosystem
to put the whole
package together.
On the devices side we've
built these new features
into the Android platform
and have worked closely
with the device OEM's
to implement them
in devices running Lollipop
and newer versions of Android.
On the applications front,
we've discussed new capabilities
in remote management that our
ISV partners are adopting,
and there's also
new VPN capabilities
in Android for Work that
allow for either per profile,
or per app VPN.
All of these new
capabilities rely
on the EMM partners that have
utilized the Android for Work
API's to build in
the capabilities
to manage the work profile,
Android for Work app, app
configuration, and per app VPN,
all from that single management
console.
So just to review.
We've talked a little
bit about the end user
features and the features
that are important to IT,
and how you can use your device
for both work and personal use.
Thank you for your
time, and I hope
you've learned some
more about Android
for Work and the capabilities
that will make it easier
to manage and secure corporate
data on Android devices,
while still allowing you to
maintain control of your device
and protect your privacy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]